cutting through the noise where I come  from people are known for being tough  but fair New York can be loud and people  tell it like it is they call it the  concrete jungle the melting pot the city  that never sleeps it's this energy that  makes it feel like home but amid the  hustle it's important to listen and pay  attention because it's not just the  loudest voices who need to be heard we  all have a story to tell I see it as my  job as a journalist to go beyond the  obvious now I'm based in Europe and my  work takes me around the world to put  questions to leaders in politics and  business but my instincts remain the  same to tell the important stories  behind the headlines because no matter  where I go the fundamentals remain what  is the heart of the story why does it  matter who will it impact you have to  stay focused if you want answers you  have to cut through the noise to get to  the truth my name is Sarah Kelley and I  work at GW  [Music]